Hi, this is the Lee Detective Agency.We accept any kind of
request.Sometimes it's a special request.
Detectives should be in the dark. If you go
out under the light, the mysteriousness
will disappear.
That's right
[music]
[music] [
music]
[music] It's
Mr. Lee's
new collection.
Mr. Moji, an executive of a certain bank, has been reported missing.  This
picture corresponds to this case.
That person
was secretly having a lover. The
two of them
ran away together just as they were being investigated.  The
plane ticket we bought
together The masterpiece of that person's bank The receipt for the jewelery that he bought  I'm
putting my property on a gold card and it's being kept by a good detective agency.I just
want my property back.
I'll
go home and sell my house You'll still be able to live for a
while Shall I make this special?
Please
wait,
can I have your autograph, Mrs. Blanket
?
What is this
smell?  I
just bought a fur product, but you're
allergic to animals It's
respect that you have a little star under your ear Why do people who are used to wearing this kind of clothes
think they're allergic?
Did someone
make a box on the first joint of their right index finger? A
murderer must be holding a knife all the time
And most of
all, he has
a throat.
[Music] You
can taste my arousal enhancer
[Applause] [
Music]
[Music]
This special effects team found the
missing bank executive
Moji the other day.  The
character has been murdered, and the
culprit has already been arrested. The
culprit is said to have been motivated by money. Well then, please
listen to the on-site interview with Chief Hoshikuma of the special effects unit.
If it wasn't for you, even
Mr. Lee
would have been deceived.